si t'étais l'algorithme de YouTube
t'afficherait quelle vidéo sur le
téléphone de ton papy au moment où il
ouvre l'application Youtube
vidéo pour le faire rire
une vidéo sur l'urgence avec moi trop le
changement climatique
ou une vidéo pour le convaincre
d'enfants à reprendre le sport
et que voudrais-tu afficher sur les
téléphones de tes parents de tes amis de
tes compatriotes ou même du président de
la République d'un certain lieu de le
bordel il ferait mieux d'aller regarder
quelle recommandation de vidéo serait
bénéfique à effectuer pour les
utilisateurs et pour la société c'est
assez question que cherche à répondre
tournesol il pourrait y arriver on veut
s'appuyer sur les avis de tout le monde
y compris toi qui regarde cette vidéo
pour nous aider va sur tournesol.app
Créer un compte choisis des vidéos que
tu veux promouvoir ou pas et comparer
deux à deux en nous disant à chaque fois
laquelle tu recommanderais davantage